Salut, c’est Romain de 1000
idées de culture générale.
Dans cette vidéo, vous allez découvrir l’essentiel
à connaître sur le thème de culture générale de
Prépa HEC de 2022, qui est « Aimer ».
Quand vous aurez terminé cette vidéo, vous
aurez une bonne perspective d’ensemble du thème
; vous saurez vous y repérer facilement ; vous
serez déjà prêt(e) à traiter la plupart
des sujets… sans vous prendre la tête.
Et en plus j’ai une bonne nouvelle : vous
n’avez pas besoin de prendre de notes !
C’est inutile parce que je vous donne la
version écrite de mon kit de survie.
Pourquoi télécharger la version écrite ?
Eh bien parce que vous y retrouverez tout ce
que je vais vous dire dans cette vidéo,
rédigé de manière très claire et très
structurée. Vous pourrez accéder directement
à une partie ou à une sous-partie du kit grâce
au plan automatisé sur la gauche de l’écran.
J’ai même ajouté de belles citations sur l’amour,
une liste de sujets de dissertation
sur le thème, et des ressources
complémentaires pour aller plus loin.
Et cerise sur le gâteau : vous pouvez créer une
copie personnelle de mon kit de survie.
Ça vous permettra de modifier le document
comme bon vous semble : vous pourrez
ajouter ou retirer ce que vous voulez,
et même changer la mise en forme bref, ce
sera votre propre document, à vous.
Pour télécharger la version écrite de mon kit
de survie, cliquez sur le lien qui s’affiche
maintenant en haut à droite de l’écran, ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description.
Grâce à ce document, vous pouvez m’écouter en
marchant dans la rue, dans le métro, ou même les
yeux fermés, allongé(e) sur votre lit.
Mais qu’est-ce que je vais vous
dire dans cette vidéo ?
Tout d’abord, je vais rapidement
vous parler des caractéristiques du thème,
et en particulier de la différence entre le
verbe « aimer » et le nom commun « amour » vous
allez voir que ce n’est pas un choix anodin.
Ensuite, je vais vous expliquer
comment définir le concept du thème,
mais aussi la dizaine de concepts importants
qui sont liés au verbe « aimer ».
Enfin, je vais vous brosser les grandes lignes
et les principaux enjeux de l’évolution des
relations amoureuses dans l’histoire de
l’humanité, ce qui vous permettra de bien
vous repérer dans le champ intellectuel sur
lequel vous devrez disserter cette année.
Vous êtes prêt(e) ?
Allez, c’est parti : écoutez-moi attentivement,
et vous serez bien plus à l’aise lors de vos
DS, mais aussi aux épreuves des concours.
Quelles sont les caractéristiques de ce thème ?
Est-ce un thème original ?
En Prépa HEC, oui : ni « aimer » ni « l’amour »
ne sont tombés depuis les années 1990. Quelques
thèmes passés s’en rapprochent toutefois
: le désir (2020), le plaisir (2013),
et aussi peut-être la passion (2005).
Après, l’amour est un thème
classique en culture générale :
c’est un thème rebattu en littérature et en art ;
le désir est une notion du programme
de philosophie de terminale ;
l’amour était le thème des
prépas scientifiques en 2019.
En conclusion, ce n’est pas
un thème très original.
Est-ce un thème précis ou large ?
D’un côté, il est précis parce que la
polysémie de l’amour est limitée ; parce que le
concept est moins vaste que d’autres (la nature,
par exemple) ; et parce que les relations
avec les autres thèmes de la pensée sont
moins nombreuses et les connexions moins faciles.
Mais de l’autre côté, ce thème est tout de même
large dans la mesure où il obsède les êtres
humains ; dans la mesure où on distingue
diverses formes d’amour ; et dans la mesure
où le verbe « aimer » renvoie à davantage
de choses que le nom commun « amour ».
En définitive, le champ intellectuel n’est
pas très grand, mais il est très fertile.
Pourquoi « aimer » et pas « l’amour » ?
L’originalité de ce thème réside dans le
choix du verbe « aimer » plutôt que du nom
commun « amour ». La différence n’est pas
fondamentale, mais elle n’est pas anodine.
« Être amoureux est un état ; aimer, un acte. »
Denis de Rougemont, L'amour et l'Occident
Ce choix a 2 implications principales :
La préférence pour la pratique. Il faut
s’intéresser davantage à la manière et à
l’expérience d’aimer, plutôt qu’aux idées
abstraites sur l’amour. On peut donc donner
une plus grande place à la littérature et à
l’histoire (par rapport à la philosophie).
L’extension des objets d’amour. Le
verbe « aimer » admet davantage d’objets
que le nom commun « amour ». Par exemple,
on ne dit pas « je ressens de l’amour pour cette
série », mais on dit bien « j’aime cette série
». On devra donc aussi s’intéresser au fait
d’aimer des choses et pas seulement des êtres.
Quelles définitions connaître ?
Comment définir le concept du thème ?
Le verbe « aimer » est transitif :
on aime quelqu’un, ou quelque chose.
Mais on peut aussi l’utiliser dans
l’absolu, c’est-à-dire sans COD. On dit
par exemple d’une femme qui a eu beaucoup
d’amants qu’« elle a beaucoup aimé ».
Sur le plan de l’étymologie, il vient du
verbe latin amare, qui a le même sens.
Mais les racines indo-européennes
d’amare expriment 3 idées :
l’idée de s’unir ;
l’idée d’aimer comme une mère aime son enfant ;
l’idée de prendre (on dit par exemple « prendre
pour époux »), qui renvoie peut-être au rapt de
la fiancée dans les sociétés anciennes.
Le verbe « aimer » a 2 sens principaux :
Éprouver pour quelqu’un une
inclination tendant à l’union.
Il s’agit donc d’une action qui se produit dans
l’esprit humain : l’acteur ressent une attirance,
qui mêle le désir et la sympathie, pour
un autre être. C’est dans ce sens qu’on
dit par exemple « aimer une femme, un homme ».
Par extension, ce sens inclut les traductions
concrètes de l’expérience
intérieure de l’attirance,
comme la dévotion d’une mère pour son enfant,
l’attachement d’un maître pour son chien, etc.
Apprécier quelque chose.
Dans ce sens également,
l’action se produit dans l’esprit humain : on
accorde de la valeur à une chose parce qu’elle
nous procure un bénéfice. On dit par exemple qu’on
aime les bonbons, le soleil, ou la solitude.
L’attirance est moins
intense dans ce second sens.
Enfin, le nom commun « amour » désigne
un intense sentiment d’attachement qui
rend l’être humain capable de faire
abnégation de son intérêt individuel.
Quels sont les concepts les plus importants ?
Voici les principaux concepts liés
au verbe « aimer » :
Affection : Attachement
tendre et durable pour un être vivant.
Témoigner de l’affection à quelqu’un.
Affinité : Harmonie entre deux
personnes qui s’entendent bien.
Deux cousins liés par une grande affinité.
Amitié : Sentiment d’attachement qu’une
personne porte à une autre, et qui n’est
fondé ni sur les liens du sang ni sur
l’amour. Se lier d’amitié avec ses voisins.
Amour-passion : Sentiment amoureux le plus
intense, au point qu’il monopolise
l’esprit de l’amoureux. La force
irrépressible de l’amour-passion.
Amour platonique : Amour sans sexualité,
c’est-à-dire purement spirituel.
Un amour qui reste platonique.
Appariement : Processus de formation des
couples chez les espèces à reproduction
sexuée. L’appariement chez les bonobos.
Attirance : Force qui entraîne une personne
vers une chose ou un être. Éprouver
de l’attirance pour quelqu’un.
Charité : Souci du prochain.
Faire une chose par pure charité.
Désir : Tendance spontanée et consciente vers
une fin connue ou imaginée. Assouvir ses désirs.
Fraternité : Lien unissant des personnes
qui, sans être frères par le sang,
se considèrent comme telles. La
fraternité des citoyens français.
Haine : Intense aversion envers une
chose ou un être. Un regard de haine.
Passion : Phénomène passif de l’âme, assez
puissant pour dominer la vie de l’esprit.
La passion amoureuse.
Séduction : Action
d’attirer. Une scène de séduction.
Sensualité : Charme d’une chose ou
d’une personne qui évoque les plaisirs
des sens. La sensualité d’une danse.
Sexualité : Division de chaque espèce en
deux genres dont l’union devient nécessaire
à la reproduction de l’espèce.
La libération de la sexualité.
Comment aime-t-on dans l’histoire de l’humanité ?
Dans cette partie, mon objectif est de vous
brosser les grandes lignes et les principaux
enjeux de l’évolution des relations amoureuses.
Voici les limites de ma synthèse :
Il est impossible de faire l’histoire
de l’action d’aimer, donc je vais surtout
me concentrer sur l’amour avec un grand A.
Comme l’amour est le thème majeur de la
culture occidentale, la quantité d’idées,
de faits, et d’œuvres qu’on peut mentionner est
infinie. C’est pourquoi je ne vais parler que de
l’évolution générale des relations amoureuses.
Ma synthèse embrasse l’histoire de l’ensemble de
l’humanité, mais comme la plupart
des travaux sur le même sujet,
elle donne une place plus importante à
l’Occident (biais géographique), d’une part,
et aux relations amoureuses hétérosexuelles
(biais hétérosexiste), d’autre part.
Gardez donc bien à l’esprit, lorsque vous lisez
ma synthèse, que l’intérêt en est d’avoir une
bonne perspective d’ensemble du thème. Ainsi, vous
vous repérerez mieux dans le champ intellectuel
sur lequel vous devrez disserter cette année.
Que sait-on de l’amour chez les premiers hommes ?
On ne connaît pas grand-chose de l’attachement et
de la sexualité chez les premiers « humains » (au
sens d’animal du genre Homo) apparus il y
a environ 2 millions d’années. On imagine
donc que cela ressemble à ce que font les
primates, et en particulier le bonobo,
qui est génétiquement très proche de l’humain.
Comme les hommes chasseurs-cueilleurs,
les bonobos forment des communautés
d’une centaine d’individus maximum.
Sur le plan de l’attachement, les
éléments suivants sont intéressants :
Tout le monde côtoie et connaît intimement
tout le monde dans un groupe « naturel » d’une
centaine de membres. L’attachement
n’est donc probablement pas exclusif,
mais plutôt partagé entre divers individus.
La promiscuité empêche certainement deux
individus de développer et d’entretenir une
relation « fusionnelle » à l’écart du groupe.
L’impossibilité de la solitude crée une dépendance
affective à l’égard des autres membres du groupe.
Sur le plan de la sexualité, on peut
retenir les éléments suivants :
Les bonobos dissocient la sexualité de la
reproduction. La majorité des actes sexuels
servent à améliorer les relations sociales
(par exemple, à réduire l’agressivité d’un
individu dominant), c’est-à-dire in
fine à assurer la survie du groupe.
Ils sont ouverts à tous types de relations
et de pratiques. Leur seul tabou sexuel est
l’inceste : aucun rapport sexuel entre
mère et fils n’a jamais été observé.
Le mâle ignore son rôle dans la reproduction.
Les mâles restent dans le groupe de naissance,
tandis que les femelles le quittent à la
puberté (probablement pour éviter l'inceste).
L’exemple des bonobos montre que l’attachement et
la sexualité sont inséparables de la configuration
de la vie collective. On peut donc faire
l’hypothèse que l’évolution de la vie
sociale entraîne l’évolution de la vie amoureuse.
Seulement, la nature de l’organisation sociale des
chasseurs-cueilleurs fait encore débat.
Deux hypothèses s’opposent :
D’après l’hypothèse (controversée) de
la « commune ancienne », les Sapiens
chasseurs-cueilleurs vivaient en tribus qui ne
connaissaient ni la propriété, ni la monogamie,
ni la paternité ils partageaient tout !
Les tenants de l’hypothèse de la « monogamie
éternelle » répondent que si la famille nucléaire
(maman, papa, enfants) est devenue la norme dans
l’immense majorité des cultures, c’est
parce qu’elle s’est imposée depuis bien
longtemps comme la solution la plus efficace pour
structurer à la base les communautés humaines.
En tout cas, une chose est certaine : l’aptitude
à aimer de l’homme moderne est en partie héritée
du chasseur-cueilleur. Vivre dans la promiscuité
de petits groupes pendant des millions d’années
nous a rendus affectivement dépendants les uns des
autres, ce qui explique le malaise psychologique
de la société post-industrielle, où les individus
sont de plus en plus confrontés à la solitude. Si
les relations sexuelles des chasseurs-cueilleurs
étaient aussi libres que celles des bonobos,
alors on comprend mieux l’ampleur
actuelle des infidélités et des divorces.
Notre capacité à éprouver de l’affection pour
certains animaux est probablement, elle aussi,
très ancienne. Les bandes de Sapiens commencent
à accueillir des chiens les bêtes à la fois les
plus attentives et les plus manipulatrices
il y a environ 40 000 ans, pour la chasse et
la sécurité. Elles sont déjà très attachées à ces
compagnons, au point qu’elles les inhument parfois
cérémonieusement comme les hommes.
Qu’est-ce qu’aimer dans les
premières sociétés élaborées ?
La vie sociale des chasseurs-cueilleurs
connaît 2 évolutions majeures :
Il y a 70 000 années, ils se
mettent à penser et à communiquer d’une
nouvelle manière c’est la « révolution
cognitive » ce qui leur permet de concevoir
des formes de coopération plus avancées.
Il y a 12 000 ans, ils deviennent des agriculteurs
c’est la « révolution « agricole » et ils se
sédentarisent pour rester près des champs.
Ces évolutions entraînent la sophistication
de la vie sociale, laquelle entraîne
la sophistication de la vie amoureuse.
Les sociétés soumettent alors les relations
amoureuses à des règles. Cette mutation
semble dictée par la perception que la
liberté sexuelle menace l'ordre social.
Ainsi apparaissent des interdits :
On prohibe l’inceste, ce qui permet
aux femmes de rester dans leur groupe de
naissance (certains ethnologues voient là
le passage de la nature à la culture).
On interdit ou on sanctuarise le célibat
parce que, d’un côté, une femme seule n'est
pas protégée ; et parce que de l’autre,
un homme seul est un danger pour l'ordre
social, car il convoite les femmes des autres.
On ritualise les relations sexuelles par
des cérémonies collectives, des danses,
des initiations, des fêtes
de libération sexuelle, etc.
On intègre les interdits
dans les récits mythiques.
Certaines sociétés vont jusqu’à encadrer
la fréquence et le déroulement même des
rapports sexuels (dans les premiers
royaumes chinois, par exemple).
Pour préserver l’ordre,
les sociétés créent également des solutions
pour stabiliser les relations homme-femme.
La première forme de stabilité relationnelle est
probablement l’organisation de mariages de groupe,
qui apparaît il y a 10 000 ans. L’historien grec
Strabon fait par exemple état de l’existence de
cette coutume chez un peuple du Tibet, et il
ajoute que Jules César l’a également observée
chez les anciens Bretons (Géographie).
Inspirés de l’appariement chez les primates,
ces mariages consistent en général à lier
un groupe de frères avec un groupe de sœurs.
Si cette configuration sert à lier des groupes
entre eux, elle n’empêche pas hommes et femmes
de se respecter, d’apprendre les uns des autres,
de converser, et de faire assaut de tendresse.
On la trouve notamment dans les communautés de
guerriers (c’est d’ailleurs le modèle choisi
par Platon dans La République).
« Les femmes, le mariage et la
procréation des enfants, toutes choses qui,
selon le proverbe, doivent être le plus possible
communes entre amis. »
Socrate, La République
À partir de la sédentarisation, presque
toutes les sociétés sont polygynes.
En voici les (probables) raisons principales :
Pour l’homme, la polygynie augmente la probabilité
d’avoir une descendance, c’est-à-dire
de transmettre effectivement ses gènes.
Ayant compris son rôle dans la procréation,
l’homme considère que les enfants sont une
force de travail qui lui appartient. Vu
sous cet angle, il a intérêt à en avoir le
plus possible, et donc à avoir plusieurs femmes.
La femme est elle-même une force de travail : elle
s’occupe des enfants, cuisine, produit des
vêtements, et travaille parfois aux champs.
Dans ce système, la femme est une ressource
précieuse révélatrice du statut social. Mais
la polygynie est surtout réservée aux riches
dans les faits. Les hommes les plus puissants
sont ceux qui possèdent le plus de femmes. Ils
achètent, échangent, voire volent des filles
et des épouses à l’extérieur du clan.
Certaines sociétés sont polyandres. La
principale motivation de cette configuration est
de ne pas diviser le patrimoine : des frères qui
partagent une seule et même femme forment une
seule et même famille (on parle de « polyandrie
fraternelle »). Une autre motivation est de
réduire l’impact démographique des guerres. En
devenant l’épouse commune de plusieurs soldats,
une femme s’assure de ne pas finir veuve.
Pourquoi la monogamie s’impose-t-elle ?
La monogamie s’impose pour 2 raisons principales.
La première raison est arithmétique. En
effet, puisqu’il naît en moyenne autant
de filles que de garçons c’est une égalité
génétique l’humanité compte (en moyenne)
autant de femmes que d’hommes. Si la polygynie se
généralisait, elle laisserait par conséquent une
majorité d’hommes célibataires. Or, les sociétés
humaines ont compris que cette configuration
met en péril l’ordre social. L’égalité des
populations féminine et masculine implique donc
l’égale répartition des femmes entre les hommes.
Cependant, la monogamie n’est pas absolue jusqu’au
premier millénaire. C’est simplement la solution à
laquelle se résolvent la majorité des plus pauvres
mais c’est une solution provisoire qui n’est
pas synonyme de fidélité. Les élites ont quant
à elles les moyens d’être polygames, et elles
jouissent d’une plus grande liberté sexuelle.
Par exemple, la société grecque de l’époque
de Socrate est loin d’être monogame. La
plupart des citoyens qui représentent 15 % de la
population ont une épouse pour tenir leur maison,
concevoir et élever leurs enfants ; des concubines
acquises ou enlevées ; et enfin des hétaïres
(compagnes, amies, amantes) qui sont parfois des
prostituées. Autre particularité parfois oubliée,
la pédérastie est répandue dans les classes
aisées et les milieux culturels (et notamment
philosophiques). Cette relation homosexuelle,
prétendument « éducative », entre un homme adulte
(l’éraste) et un jeune garçon (l’éromène), est
une véritable institution de la Grèce antique.
Vers le milieu du Ier millénaire, partout en
Orient et en Occident, en Europe, en Afrique,
en Asie, en Amérique, concubinage, prostitution,
polygynie, mariages forcés, mariages d’enfants,
« droit de cuissage » sont encore la règle.
La seconde raison de la diffusion de la monogamie
est idéologique. La religion chrétienne en fait
le socle de l’organisation sociale en Occident.
Voici les fondements de l’idéal
chrétien de la monogamie absolue :
Une société monogame se reproduit sans conquêtes,
c’est-à-dire sans violence (contrairement à
une société polygyne où les hommes les plus
puissants cherchent à accumuler les femmes).
Les hommes monogames consacrent leur
énergie à leur foi plutôt qu’aux femmes.
La vie doit se reproduire malgré la
dimension diabolique de la sexualité.
L’homme ne doit avoir qu’une seule femme
tout comme il n’a qu’un seul Dieu.
L’amour éternel entre les époux est
calqué sur leur amour éternel pour Dieu.
À partir de cet idéal, l'Église norme et ritualise
progressivement les relations amoureuses dans un
univers polygyne. Elle diabolise la sexualité
et divinise la chasteté. Elle rend le mariage
indissoluble, interdit le divorce, ainsi que les
remariages. Elle incite les couples chrétiens à
ne pas chercher le plaisir, mais uniquement
la procréation, dans leurs rapports sexuels.
Elle impose le célibat aux prêtres.
« Vivre avec son épouse comme un frère,
sans aucun rapport conjugal,
ayant une épouse comme n’en ayant pas,
ce qui est le degré de
perfection le plus excellent
et le plus élevé dans le mariage des chrétiens. »
Saint Augustin, De sermone Domini in Monte
En pratique, cependant, l’Église peine à imposer
l’idéal chrétien. Malgré sa mainmise progressive
sur l’administration de l’Empire romain,
elle échoue à faire changer les mœurs de
son temps. Pendant les premiers siècles, elle
proclame sans relâche les mêmes interdictions,
preuve de son incapacité à les faire respecter.
Il faudra plus de mille ans pour que la monogamie
s'impose. Elle s’installe à partir du XIe
siècle en France et en Angleterre par l’action
de l’État ; et en Flandre, en Allemagne ou en
Italie par les villes. Mais dans les faits,
la société reste païenne et anarchique...
Comment l’amour devient-il un mythe occidental ?
L’Amour avec un grand A naît en
Occident entre les XIe et XVe siècles.
Comment l’expliquer ?
La première raison est
sociologique. Avec la fin des invasions barbares,
la vie sociale se stabilise et se développe,
donc les interactions entre les deux sexes sont
plus fréquentes. Les hommes et les femmes se
croisent plus ouvertement sur les marchés et
dans les églises. Ils apprennent à s’y parler
sans que leurs paroles soient des ordres ou des
marques de soumission. La séduction prend une
plus grande place dans leurs vies.
La deuxième raison réside
dans les croisades (1095-1291) :
Les soldats chrétiens découvrent la polygamie
musulmane, la poésie érotique arabe et les grands
thèmes de la théologie familiale d'Orient.
De nombreux chevaliers célibataires
convoitent les femmes, riches et seules,
voire veuves, des seigneurs partis au combat.
Ces femmes, qui contrôlent parfois les propriétés,
sont désormais libres d’aimer et de se laisser
désirer en suivant le seul élan de leur cœur.
Cette configuration sociale inédite donne
naissance à « l’amour courtois » (c'est-à-dire
tel que pratiqué dans les cours). Comme la dame
est, de par son statut social, inatteignable
pour le chevalier célibataire, celui-ci fantasme,
survalorise l’objet de son désir, et fait de sa
conquête la grande affaire de son existence.
« La femme ne doit se livrer,
proportionnellement aux mérites de l'aimé,
que par degrés et selon le procès prévu. »
Un traité de l’époque
C’est dans ces conditions
que surgit la littérature d’amour au XIIe
siècle. Les troubadours qui parcourent les
châteaux des pays de langue d’oc subliment
la sexualité dans leur poésie. Ils chantent
la gloire d’une femme intouchable et désirée, en
général imaginaire ou épouse d’un seigneur. Ils
véhiculent la conception d’un amour impossible,
où l’obstacle est essentiel à la passion. C’est
au cours de ce même siècle qu’apparaît le premier
grand récit d’amour courtois, Tristan et Iseut,
dont les reprises constitueront un pan essentiel
de la littérature romanesque en ancien français.
La troisième raison de la naissance du mythe
occidental de l’amour est le progrès de
l’idée du consentement dans le mariage :
L’Église admet que les conjoints doivent
s’aimer et considère même le mariage
sans amour comme un péché (certains
évêques le comparent à un adultère).
Elle en déduit que le consentement des
parents n’est plus nécessaire. Le théologien
Pierre Lombard, puis les papes Alexandre III
et Innocent III entérinent l’idée.
Cette évolution idéologique est une
mutation plus profonde qu’il n’y paraît. En effet,
elle contribue à faire de la relation amoureuse
une affaire privée. Les hommes et les femmes ne
doivent plus s’unir uniquement pour structurer à
la base la société et pour la reproduire, mais
pour concrétiser un attachement authentique.
On peut donc y voir une des manifestations de
la naissance de l’individualisme occidental.
Cependant, le mythe occidental de l’amour
a encore une influence très limitée.
Le mariage est toujours un mécanisme de
reproduction sociale. Ce sont souvent les
enjeux d’héritage qui dictent les unions :
il faut faire un « bon » mariage. Les filles
obéissent donc aux parents. Les nobles
sont mariées dès l’âge de 14 ou 15 ans,
tandis que celles issues des classes populaires
le sont plus tardivement, vers 18 ou 19 ans.
Les pratiques prohibées par l’Église
demeurent. Les rois continuent de
répudier leurs femmes à leur guise. Au XIIIe
siècle, un vassal ou un serf peut se marier
sans l’accord de son seigneur, mais le
droit de cuissage se perpétue. Enfin,
il y a encore des ventes d’épouses.
Pourquoi aimer devient-il la
grande affaire de l’humanité ?
Aujourd’hui, l’amour est ce qui
donne tout son sens à nos existences. La preuve en
est que l’univers s’écroule lorsque la solitude,
la séparation ou la mort nous empêchent d’aimer.
C’est vrai non seulement en Occident, mais aussi
dans le reste du monde, où se diffusent
progressivement les modèles occidentaux.
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là ?
Pour répondre, il faut tout d’abord
distinguer 2 formes d’amour :
l’amour-passion (traditionnellement
hétérosexuel, mais pas que) ;
l’amour des parents pour leurs enfants.
L’amour-passion gagne en importance à partir
du XVe siècle pour 3 raisons principales.
La première raison est que, comme au
début du millénaire, l’évolution de la
société rend les interactions entre les deux
sexes plus fréquentes. Dans toute l’Europe,
hommes et femmes se rencontrent un peu plus
facilement chez les uns et chez les autres,
dans des lieux publics ou privés. Les aventures
se multiplient, et le clergé est de plus en plus
sollicité par l’un ou l’autre des partenaires pour
consacrer une aventure d’un soir par un mariage.
Les femmes se considèrent de moins en moins comme
des proies, d’où le développement de la séduction,
et notamment de l’art de la conversation.
« Sans la parole, le plaisir de l'amour
diminue au moins des deux tiers. »
Casanova, Histoire de ma vie
La deuxième raison est la libération de la
sexualité. L’amour prend le pouvoir d’abord
en Italie et en France, tandis qu’à Bruges,
Anvers ou Amsterdam, l’éthique capitaliste
fait passer les relations amoureuses au
second plan (la priorité est de s’enrichir).
La ville qui illustre la libération sexuelle de
la Renaissance est Venise. L’amour libre et le
libertinage y deviennent si bien la règle, y
compris dans les monastères et les couvents,
qu’il est mal vu de se marier. C’est dans cette
atmosphère qu’émerge la figure du libertin.
Mais la sexualité de l’époque est bien plus
libre que ne le souhaite l’Église dans tous
les milieux. Il n’est pas rare que la première
naissance ait lieu moins de neuf mois après le
mariage. Les thèmes de la sexualité et de l’amour
se développent tant dans la littérature que dans
la réalité vécue. Ils inspirent de nouvelles
audaces artistiques et intellectuelles.
La révolution culturelle des années 1960
approfondit et démocratise la libération
sexuelle occidentale. On revendique désormais
publiquement les pratiques autrefois condamnées
par la morale sociale (mais tolérées). Les
féministes soulèvent la question du plaisir
féminin. L’avortement est largement légalisé
dans les années 1970 (en 1975 en France). Les
homosexuels militent pour leurs droits civiques
et affirment leur identité, comme le montre
le biopic Harvey Milk, du nom du premier homme
politique ouvertement homosexuel aux États-Unis.
« Vivre sans temps mort, jouir sans entraves. »
Slogan de Mai 68
La troisième raison du développement de
l’amour-passion est l’avènement du consentement
dans le mariage. À partir du XVe siècle, les
enfants se passent de plus en plus de l’accord
des parents, comme l’illustrent les conflits
entre les jeunes amoureux et leurs familles,
plus pragmatiques, dans le théâtre de Molière.
La normalisation des mariages d’amour entraîne
le reflux de la polygamie (même si elle ne
disparaît pas). Au XVIIe siècle, le nombre de
naissances illégitimes qui sont pour l’essentiel
les fruits de relations maître/servante décroît
partout en Europe, et le siècle suivant, la
société entière commence à critiquer la polygamie
des rois chrétiens (notamment en France).
L’amour parental gagne en importance à partir
du XVe siècle pour 2 raisons principales.
La première raison est démographique. C’est la
conséquence de la peste noire, qui tue entre 30 et
50 % des Européens en cinq ou six ans (1347-1352).
Tant de parents, d’amis, de jeunes sont morts
qu’on prend désormais soin de la vie. La mortalité
infantile est encore élevée, mais les parents
aiment et protègent leurs enfants plus que jamais.
Les oncles et les grands-parents continuent
de se substituer aux géniteurs disparus.
La deuxième raison est le mariage d’amour.
Le consentement introduit l’affection dans
le mariage, et donc dans la famille. En Europe,
l’attitude des parents à l’égard de l’enfant
change à la fin XVIIe siècle. Alors qu’ils lui
donnaient une valeur inférieure à celle d’un
adulte, ils le voient désormais comme un être
sacré, digne de sacrifice. Autrefois, la perte
d’un enfant était un événement négligeable
; aujourd’hui, c’est la pire horreur que
puisse vivre une famille. Mais contrairement
à ce qu’on croit, ce n’est pas la baisse de
la mortalité infantile qui est responsable
de l’évolution du sentiment des parents.
Comment expliquer le déclin de l’idéal monogame ?
Cette évolution commence grosso modo
à la fin du XIXe siècle en Occident.
La première explication est que l’amour-passion
est, par nature, instable. L’amoureux ne sait pas
quand est né son sentiment, ni quand il finira.
Tel est le principal argument des critiques du
mariage d’amour : il n’est pas raisonnable de
structurer la société à la base sur un lien
aussi mystérieux qu’éphémère. Montaigne,
déjà, recommande par exemple dans ses Essais de
faire un mariage de raison, de traiter sa femme
avec une douce amitié, et de cantonner la passion
amoureuse hors du ménage. Les faits lui donneront
raison : nombreux sont les mariages d’amour où
les époux finissent par se haïr dans les mariages
arrangés, ils finissent parfois par s’aimer.
« On s’étudie trois semaines ; on s’aime trois
mois ; on se dispute trois ans ;
on se tolère trente ans,
et les enfants recommencent. »
Taine, Vie et opinions de M.
Frédéric-Thomas Graindorge
Les partisans du mariage
d’amour admettent qu’il ne peut pas durer si
l’affection des époux ne se transforme pas pour
surmonter la dissipation de la passion initiale.
La deuxième raison du déclin de l’idéal monogame
est l’évolution de l’environnement :
L’effondrement de la famille,
et plus généralement de la communauté, ces
deux derniers siècles rend les individus
plus libres de vivre des histoires d’amour.
L’arrivée des femmes sur le marché du travail
(à partir de la Première Guerre
mondiale) et la mixité des études
décuplent les interactions entre les deux sexes.
Les femmes qui travaillent sont économiquement
indépendantes, tandis que les femmes au
foyer dépendaient de l’assistance d’un mari.
Les progrès de la contraception et
les nouvelles solutions pour avorter
minimisent le « coût » potentiel de l’acte
sexuel (en particulier pour les femmes).
Au XXIe siècle, internet et les applications
de rencontre rendent les aventures amoureuses
potentiellement illimitées.
La troisième raison est
l’évolution des mentalités :
Le christianisme, la religion
à l’origine de l’idéal de l’amour monogame,
décline en Europe depuis la fin du XIXe siècle.
À partir de la même époque, l’idéologie
féministe dédiabolise le plaisir féminin et
encourage les épouses à ne plus se soumettre
à leurs maris. Elle se prolonge le siècle
suivant dans la théorie du genre, qui remet
en cause la légitimité de l’idéal monogame
traditionnel et les stéréotypes de genre.
Les sociétés occidentales, et en particulier
les jeunesses, deviennent hédonistes
dans la seconde moitié du XXe siècle.
La multiplication des aventures amoureuses
apparaît donc comme un ingrédient du bonheur.
Dans la société de consommation,
les publicitaires s’efforcent de
convertir le désir amoureux en désir d’achat.
Plus généralement, le mouvement d’extension
des libertés individuelles semble condamner
toute forme d’engagement à la précarité.
La quatrième raison est l’évolution des
institutions. C’est désormais l’État
qui prend le contrôle des relations
amoureuses à la place de l’Église.
Les règles qui encadrent les appariements
changent progressivement. Par exemple,
le Code civil de Bonaparte (1804) rend le
mariage religieux facultatif. Le mariage
civil se généralise en Occident au XIXe siècle,
ce qui transforme un engagement indissoluble
devant Dieu en un accord dont l’effectivité est
soumise à conditions. Les mariages des couples
de même sexe sont progressivement légalisés
dans le monde à partir des années 2000.
Ensuite, les lois facilitent la séparation.
En France, par exemple, l’autorisation du
divorce pour incompatibilité d'humeur en 1793
entraîne un déluge de demandes. Devenu un sujet
de plaisanterie (notamment au théâtre),
l’adultère est dépénalisé. En Occident,
le nombre de divorces explose au tournant du XXe
siècle il est multiplié par 15 environ —, puis
la pratique se banalise au tournant du XXIe
siècle : plus d’un mariage sur trois finit en
divorce en Occident (45 % en France), et
un mariage sur quatre est un remariage.
Dans le monde actuel, l’Église catholique
influence encore les décisions et rituels
de mariage pour environ un milliard d’êtres
humains, et diverses formes de christianisme
encadrent l’appariement pour un autre milliard. Un
autre milliard encore vit sous la loi de l’islam.
Le restant de l’humanité, c’est-à-dire presque
toute l’Asie et une partie de l’Afrique, vit,
comme depuis des millénaires, en situation plus
ou moins polygyne : les gens se marient hors de
tout lieu de culte, avec parfois la présence
d’un religieux ou selon un rituel ancestral,
et avec, de plus en plus, une
cérémonie copiée sur les formes
profanes du modèle du mariage catholique,
aujourd’hui symbole de la modernité.
Ça y est : c’est terminé !
Je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
télécharger la version écrite de mon kit de
survie : cliquez sur le lien qui s’affiche
maintenant en haut à droite de l’écran, ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description.
Avant de vous laisser, j’ai une question
pour vous : et si vous pouviez jeter
votre cours sur le thème à la poubelle ?
Et si vous pouviez réussir les dissertations de
culture générale des concours, mais aussi les DS
de votre prépa… avec seulement 10 pages ?!
Depuis que j’ai popularisé ma méthode
des paragraphes en 2016, les élèves qui
l’adoptent gagnent rapidement des points.
Tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps !
Ça vous intéresse ?
Je vous révèle les 5 étapes de ma méthode dans
la vidéo qui apparaît maintenant à l’écran.
Vous pouvez également la trouver en
écrivant « Prépa HEC méthode des paragraphes
» dans la barre de recherche de YouTube.
Regardez-la attentivement jusqu’au bout, et vous
saurez exactement comment gagner facilement des
points en dissertation de culture générale cette
année... tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps.